hey this is preshtalwalker
think of a two-digit number
add up the digits of the number together
subtract your result from your original
number
i want you to focus on this number i'll
call this your magic number
in the following table locate your magic
number
and concentrate on the symbol next to
your number
if you have the number four for example
i want you to concentrate on the symbol
of the person on the motorcycle
are you concentrating on your symbol
all right i'm going to try and read your
mind now
you're looking at the symbol of an eye
did i get it correct
if you followed the directions correctly
i did make the correct prediction
why is this let's go through the steps
a two-digit number can be represented by
a binomial 10x plus y
when you add up the digits of the number
that becomes the number x plus y
if you subtract the sum of the digits
from the original number the y's will
cancel out so you have 10x minus x which
is equal to 9x
i don't know what your original number
is i don't know what the sum of your
digits are
but i know your magic number will be a
multiple of nine
in the table there will always be the
same symbol for the multiples of nine
and that's the i
thanks for watching this video please
subscribe to my channel i make videos on
math and game theory you can catch me on
my blog mind your decisions which you
can follow on facebook google plus and
patreon
you can catch me on social media at
preshtalwalker and if you like this
video please check out my books there
are links in the video description